Ukrainian officials say another round of
intensive Russian aerial bombardment has
hit the capital kiev for now they say
the defense systems are coping with the
attacks the strikes happened just hours
after Russia agreed to extend the deal
allowing Ukrainian grain to pass freely
through the Black Sea for another two
months Andrew Simmons reports
the skyline above Kiev shows which
direction this war is heading Ukraine's
military says the intensity of attacks
from the air is unprecedented yet most
of the damage caused in this latest wave
of airstrikes appears to have been
limited because of the success of
Ukraine's air defenses particularly the
U.S Patriot missile system
inevitably debris often lands in
residential areas here's what remains of
one Russian missile
there was a very powerful explosion then
I saw the smoke I found out the debris
fell down on the garages mine is nearby
I can see the missile debris here now
terrifying for civilians maybe but for
now many lives are being saved Ukraine's
military says 29 out of 30 missiles were
destroyed in this Spate of attacks
Russia dismisses such claims one comment
saying Ukraine is claiming to have taken
out more missiles than were actually
fired among the latest military action
was an explosion that derailed a train
carrying supplies of grain in Crimea
territory which was annexed by Russia in
2014. the rail company is reported to be
treating the explosion as sabotage
on the issue of grain supplies comes a
positive development on diplomacy an
agreement for Ukraine to export millions
of tons of grain through the Black Sea
has been extended for two months
considering appeals by our partners we
have supported the Turkish president
erdogan's initiative announced yesterday
to extend the deal for two months more
but it should be clearly understood that
these two months are going to be the
decisive ones
but other attempts at diplomacy in this
war are failing Ukraine's foreign
minister dimitro kulaba met with a
Chinese Diplomat on Wednesday but
dismissed any peace deal that would mean
Ukraine giving up territory to Russia
for now Ukraine is still getting ready
for a counter-offensive
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera
okay for more Let's cross to Moscow and
speak to Yulia Chapel valova how is the
extension to the grain deal going down
in Moscow Yulia
why did Russia kept saying for weeks
about a lack of consensus and seemingly
insurmountable obstacles the deal has
been extended at least for two months as
we know we don't hear much from the
Russian side there are just some
official statements so to speak we've
just heard from foreign minister lavrov
he said next two months will be decisive
for the deal and that its extension is
not related to the presidential
elections in Turkey obviously it's
evident of course how important for Mr
erdogan is to successfully broker the
grain deal as he continues running for
president and Edwin also said that
turkey received guarantees from its
Russian friends for this saved departure
of Turkish ships from the ports of
Nikolai and Albia in Ukraine because
earlier Deputy foreign minister of
Russia sergeant said the Turkish ships
could not leave the polls due to
security reasons because of Mind areas
and dangerous Fairways also about
reactions according to foreign Ministry
spokesperson Marie is Harbor Russia
makes real steps with not just words but
Deeds to help ensure Global Food
Security First of all to help countries
most in need but she said Russia would
stick to its demands and all the
distortions in the implementation of the
grain deal should be corrected as
quickly as possible meanwhile bacillini
benzia Russia's Parliament
representative to to the U.N said Moscow
agreed to the extension of the grain
deal as it hopes that the problems in
its implementation will be resolved so
as we see Russia continues to demand the
Fulfillment of its conditions and Moscow
repeatedly criticized the implementation
of the agreement saying that the
conditions are in favor of the Ukrainian
side but Russia also has its interests
and talking about Russia's demands back
in April the Russian foreign Ministry
announced five conditions for the
extending of the grain deal and all of
them have to be observed of course
thank you very much indeed